pub
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouais
ce ne sont pas les girls des folies
bergères mais les patineuses du numéro à
grand spectacle holiday on ice qui se
déroule au nouveau palais des sports a
pas
[Musique]
spectacle qui enthousiasme les
spectateurs par son faste et sa
perfection
jugez en vous même
[Musique]
il
pas une fausse note c'est presque aussi
beau qu'un rêve
[Musique]
ouverture des jeux olympiques d'hiver à
squaw valley en californie les
traditionnels des différentes
délégations nationales qui participait
aux jeux olympiques
les concurrents contassot d'élégance
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire
[Musique]
c'est monsieur richard nixon le vice
président des états unis qui déclare les
jeux olympiques ouvert
[Applaudissements]
olympique est hissé deux mille pigeons
symbole de paix et d'amitié sont lâchés
avant la fin de la cérémonie
tandis qu'on allume le flambeau
olympique dont la flamme ne s'éteindra
qu'à la fin du
la première médaille d'or est décerné
aux canadiens rabat paul et babar awan
air qui gagnent l'épreuve de patinage
artistique par couple
[Musique]
l'américaine penny pitou ouvre la piste
pour la descente féminine
parcours impeccable arrivé en bolide est
la poussée des pointes à 105 à l'heure
mais ce ne sera pas suffisant pour
gagner
la gagnante la voici c'est l'allemande
heidi pis pour eux encore plus étonnante
que penny pitou qui termine cependant la
seconde place derrière à gibbs
en gagnant la descente olympique à des
bébés redonna l'allemagne la première
place en ski féminin
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le rêve d'einstein est il réalisé par
delà sa formule traduisant la relativité
du temps et de l'espace
il en cherche est une autre regroupant
toutes les lois de l'univers
un physicien français de 39 ans jean
charron spécialiste de l'énergie
thermonucléaire semble avoir trouver
l'équation universel toutes les lois
connus ou à découvrir tiendrait dans
cette formule
cette équation que vous avez trouvé
affirme t-elle tous les principes de
l'univers dans la mesure où cette eau
théorie est exact elle devrait permettre
non seulement de retrouver les lois déjà
connu de la nature mais encore de
prévoir les nouvelles lois qui n'ont pas
encore été découverte
est ce que votre théorie a été vérifiée
nous avons commencé la vérification de
ces équations sur machines électroniques
et les résultats obtenus jusque
maintenant paraissent très satisfaisant
[Musique]
constantinople qu'on a aujourd'hui
istanbul n'est plus depuis 1923 la
capitale de la turquie
elle prend rang verrière ankara mais
elle garde toujours sur sa rivale avec
ses deux de ces minarets avec la masse
énorme de sainte sophie et le
grouillement des quais de galata cette
revanche de rester sous ses phares de
vieilles courtisane la plus fabuleuse et
la plus poignante gardienne du bosphore
à istanbul la ligne sur ses quais les
mosquées les palets ou s'endormit comme
s'ils étaient endormis byzance la
puissance du vieil empire ossements lee
[Musique]
la vraie turquie aujourd'hui elle est
sur la rive d'asie où l'ombre d'atatürk
affirme qu'elle continue l'europe sur
ses plateaux d'un atelier où mustapha
kemal résolu de replier l'état pour leur
bâtir à partir de zéro c'est de ce jour
qu'ankara devint capitale
ankara conserve encore des quoi presque
villageois du temps où elle se nommait
embarras et des débuts de son élévation
quelques toitures de bidonvilles
[Musique]
tout le reste à 30 ans 10 ans ou six
mois ankara et le triomphe de
l'imagination créatrice
[Musique]
que cette ville moderne avec ses
buildings et ses avenues ou les
automobiles croisent toujours les
attelages d'un autre temps étaient
étirées du néant
il faut aujourd'hui un effort
d'imagination pour le concevoir ici il
fallu apporter jusqu au bois des
charpentes met le doigt d'atatürk grefa
sur un poussière aux abandons la
capitale qu'ils voulaient celle qui ne
devrait rien à personne sinon à lui et à
son peuple
angora comptait vingt mille habitants
ankara en compte 300 me ou aujourd'hui
un peuple se pressent aux portes des
cinémas s'étendait aussi 40 ans des
marais et des bourbiers ou aujourd'hui
le match de football fenerbahçe
galatasaray rempli le stade d'une foule
aussi pressé que démonstrative c'était
hier des marécages où régnait la malaria
créer une ville est simple faire un
peuple moderne d'une population il est
très attaché aux pratiques et aux modes
d'un moyen-âge attardé et certainement
plus complexe l'école compte parmi les
grandes batailles de la turquie quand
aujourd'hui on voit les classes
enfantines dessinée dans l'air les
lettres de l'alphabet il faut se
souvenir que d'un trait de plume atatürk
remplace à l'écriture sous fit par
l'écriture romaine et du même coup fait
basculer la turquie dans le monde
moderne
[Applaudissements]
le guide le plus sûr dans la vie c'est
la science l'axiome favori d'atatürk
trouve aujourd'hui son triomphe dans la
vision de ces groupes d'étudiants qui
sont peut-être à travers le monde les
plus assidus et les plus studieux
cette jeune turquie d'ankara se refuse à
dormir dans le murmure des sourates ou
sans l'isère tant de générations entre
au 15 mai route
même chez les adultes la fièvre
d'apprendre reste puissante dans cette
ville sortie du néant qui sont ces
élèves dont la moitié au moins son chef
de famille des fonctionnaires des
commerçants des employés
ils suivent à l'université les classes
de français le voyageur pensera que
c'est en effet d'une utilité
incontestable devant les enseignes en
renonçant à l'écriture souffle la langue
turque a fait de nombreuses empreintes
en particulier aux français
phonétiquement on s'y retrouve mais on a
des surprises
[Musique]
créations insolites ankara par est le
symbole même de cette turquie nouvelle
qui s'est refaite sur les terrasses
désolé ou galopeur les petits chevaux de
gengis quand le vent des steppes
parcours encore les boulevards d'ankara
dont les avenues des bouches sans
faubourg sur le désert mais ankara et la
capitale
héroïque d'une création héroïque la
statue de kemal qui prit le nom
d'atatürk le père des turcs domine tout
cela il dort lui tout près de son rêve
réalisé dans ce tombeau monumental ou
veille sans cesse 300 thiney
entre le pays et le présent de la
turquie il n'est d'autre lien que lui
atatürk
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]